お弟子さん質問する？じゃあ質問します
長老一つよろしいですか
あのですね 自分がものすごい無茶苦茶な妄想をしてる
破壊的な妄想とかですね
とんでもないことを考えてるなっていう時がいまだにものすごいあるんです
それは あの まあ妄想なんですけども
過去世でしたようなことをやっぱり思い出すもんですか
それともこんなことした
したことないんですけど
勝手に思い出すもんなんですかね
例えば自分が働いているお寺さんでですね
ちょっと外を見てみると
大きな灯油を入れてるタンクがあるんです
これ火つけたら面白いよなと勝手に思ってるんですよ
これは無茶苦茶なことを思ってましてね
それだけで止まらないで
こういうタンクは多分他の寺にもいっぱいあるから
これ全部に火つけたらこれはもうすごいことになるぞとか
もうすごい妄想を働かせて
それでびっくりしまして
これはモソモソして慌てて切るという感じなんですけど
そういう無茶苦茶悪いことはですね
かつてしてたんでしょうか
教えてください  まああの
まあ妄想は妄想ですけど
まず妄想はなんでこうとかね
まあこれかつてやっていたこととか
そういうあの 何か理由を探すのは良くないんですよ
そうするとなくならないんですよ
私は過去生からこんな妄想でいたでしょうということは
しょうがないという答えなんですよ
しょうがない どうぞという答えですから
それはやるんじゃないんです
もうこんなくだらん妄想
もうやめろと すぐやめなくちゃいけない
どうしてもこれでは回転するんだ
誰かともう知らない人で
まあちょっと今日は何曜日とか何とか聞いて
でもあの これ知らなくちゃいけないんですね
だからキーっと回転しちゃうとカチッと止まる
また回転する それで成長するんであって
なんで回転しているのかと探すんじゃないんです
例えばボールを投げたところで間違った方向行ってるんだと
あ こういう風にカーブやったんだから
だから窓 人の窓まで行く
そんなどうでもいいでしょう
もうだから早く窓に当たる前に先に何とかしてね
それをボールを何とかすることなんですね
だから 誰でも妄想が出てきちゃうと
もう切るんであって 他に何もやるんじゃないんです
理由はどうでもいいんです
言い訳はどうでもいいんです
とにかく切る それしか方法ない
これはブッダがブッダに言われたんだから
もう誰にももう何とか何とか言えることはできないんです
切りなさい それで終わり
言い訳を探すんじゃないんです
まあそれからまあ男っていうのは
なんかそういういい加減なことはやっぱり考えることは考えますけど
まあそこまではやっぱり考えない方がいいと思います
ちょっと微妙ないたずらみたいなものはね
あの人 なんとかこうした方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
例えば犬飼人がここに何かちょこっと置いておいた方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
まあそれ程度だったらね
いたずらもそうもうそんなに
まあ危険じゃないんだけど
まあ全部全国の寺の灯油タンクに気をつけようまでは
やっぱり気をつけた方がいいんですね
まあそれ単なる自分がふざけて面白がってることだと思いますけどね
面白そうだなと思っちゃうだけでね
まあそういうことはね
もっとまあいい方向へ変えるとかね
まあここら辺にいっぱい花が植えたらどうでしょうかとかね
あるいはこの灯油タンクをね
なんか絵でも描いて なんかお化けのような絵を描いて
なんかびっくりするようなことにしたらどうでしょうかとかね
まあそういうふうなことを妄想しちゃうと
なんとなくデザイン的なものだからね
妄想はろくなことではないんだけど
もしかするとたまたま役に立ってしまう可能性もありますしね
まあとにかく切るというね
切る方法だけ 自分で妄想しても切れなかったらもう
そこら辺通ってる人と話しかけたってもよろしいし
だから激しい妄想を切るためだと思って
そこら辺の女の人が歩いて
その人女の人をナンパしようと
あの間にすごくものすごく怒鳴られても
もうほっぺたを殴られたならそれでもいいんです
別に他の人からなんたんでもないスケベと言われたっても
自分がそんなことやったわけじゃなくて
自分の妄想の回転を止めさせ止めさせたかっただけで
だからとにかく何とかしてそれを切るということで
はい  以前にですね 無常についてお尋ねしたことがあるんですけど
無常  無常 以前 無常についてお尋ねしたことがあるんですけれども
その時回答が森羅万象は無常であるとお答えいただいたんですけれども
この森羅万象の中には自我が私というのは入るんでしょうか
自我と私っていうのは幻覚ですからね
結局は 幻覚ってのは存在しないんですね
だから幻覚っていうのは
例えばウサギの角 ないでしょ？亀の毛とかね
亀の毛ないんでしょ？だから森羅万象の中に亀の毛も入ってますかというと
入ってないでしょ そんなもともとないんだからね
この自我っていうのはもともとないんです
我々はあると錯覚しているんです
だから悟りでその錯覚を破れます
錯覚が破れるだけ なんか大事な自我があって
それがなくなったわけじゃないんです
大事な自我があって これが壊れちゃったということじゃないんです
錯覚がなくなったということで
錯覚をなくすにはどういう？まあこのヴィパッサナー瞑想
だから森羅万象を観察することですよ
そうすると無常であるということが分かりますからね
無常ですから 自我があるわけないでしょう
結局は 別に錯覚  ありがとうございます
はい この間仙台でお話しされたことと今日のお話ともあれなんですけども
なんというか その自分が明らかに壁を張って限界を作ってるっていうのはわかってるんで
ですけども そこの壁に近づいて超えようと思って引き返すところに何か奇妙な心地よさみたいなものを感じてしまって
なんかこれがこれくだらん
本当に邪魔で意味がないんですけど
これこそがなんか自分のやり方なんだという奇妙な雰囲気で
全然そこが超えれないという
こういう心のなんか心地から抜けられなくて
いつもこうレベルの低いところで堂々巡りを繰り返してる人生だと思うんですけども
うーんという 先生はこの間勇気を持ってという感じでおっしゃったんですけども
でも果たしてその  今日もう一回
毎回同じ質問するんだからね
もう私もネタ切れになりますよね
はい ですから まあ一つ例え話を言います
ある人がずっとお茶漬け食べている
朝起きてすごくお腹が空いちゃって
さっさとお茶漬けを食べて
よかった おいしかった
それで昼まだお腹が空いてくると
またお茶漬けを食べる
また晩ご飯にお茶漬け食べる
毎日毎日お茶漬けばっかり食べている
そうすると当然買い物をする場合も同じものを買うでしょ
その人にとってはこれっていうのはもう晩ご飯時間になってくるともうお茶漬けの匂いが出てきて
朝目が覚めたらお茶漬けの味が出てきてとかね
それで誰がね あのね この朝も昼も晩も同じものを食うのはやめたらどうですかと言うと
腹立たしんですよ せっかく美味しいものを食べてるのに
だからこの人はもう海苔も海苔ちょこっとつけてみろというと
やったことないんだからね
ごちそうじゃないんだけど
おにぎりでも食べてみろと
だっておにぎりの場合は中の具っていろいろ変わるんだからね
でもやったことないんだから
やっぱりお茶漬けが美味しいっていうことになるんです
そういうところなんです
もっと美味しいものあるんだけど
もっと居心地のいいものはいっぱいあるんだけど
壁を破っていれば お茶漬けだけでもう止まっちゃいるんですよ
終わり 話は だから で 残りはあなたの知識的にでしょう
いや だからお茶漬けを食べて満足してるんだったら
もうあえて  でももっともっと科学的に考えると
人がずっとお茶漬けばっかりばっかり食ってると
これ栄養失調でしょうね
健康にならんでしょうね
早死になるでしょうね
それでもその人はもうすごい刺激があって
美味しくてそこで止まってるっていうことは正しいかないかと
満足しているってことは答えじゃないでしょうね
この人はもっといいものを知らないだけだけでしょうね
お新香ぐらいで食ったらどうでしょうかと
お茶漬けばっかり食べたい人ってお新香出たらなんかちょっとこれって思うかもしれませんよ
でももうちょこっと食べてみればこれ美味しくなるんです
我々外人たちは初めてわさび食べたらこれ殺されるんだ
これ毒じゃないかと あんた顔見ろ
日本人 何なのこの人 毒食べさせると
でも一回はものすごいショックなんですよ
涙が出て 鼻水が出てもう
頭のてっぺんまで痛くなって
もう 死ぬかと思うんですけどね
でも今私はもうとにかくわさびをわさわさと食べる
あったら 時々どこかでアイスクリームとアイスクリームがあまり私の体に合わないんだけど
わさびの味のわさびじゃったらかったんだけど
そこで熱海どこら辺であのわさび漬けというなんとかあって
一回だけ買ったことありますけどね
ご飯にそれ食べて辛さ足らんな
これは じゃあ古いんじゃないかとかね
いうことになってるんです
今度飛行機で来る時でも
もうご飯 2回出ましたけど
最初はまあ夜とかでそれやめちゃって
次はもう朝方でね もう降りる前にまた一応ご飯くれるんですね
その時のリストに蓋がすごく嫌なものが一つあるんですよ
そばちょこっとありまして
この緑色であれって本当にそばじゃないと思いますけどね
あの飛行機機内食のように
なんとかメリケン粉で作ってると思いますけど
まずいといえばね 全部アウトにするんです
まあ一応いろいろ注文できるんだから
我々セクションでね でもこれどういうことで聞いたらわさびあるんですね
あ わさびくれるそうですだったんです
そばが好きでしたのではなくて
わさびが食べたかったんです
でもあまりいいわさびではなかったんです
もうそんなにね いいわさびではない
だからそんなもんです
だから一回目はもう殺されると思ったんですけどね
なんかこの人々にもすごく調子に乗って
外人何も知らんから馬鹿にするんじゃないよとかね
気持ちにはなったんだけど
それそれから次々行ってみると
これって結構立派な食べ物だなとなるんですよ
だから初めての経験というかね
まあだから我々ちっちゃな壁作ってそこでぶつかってみて
こう まあやっぱり止まるっていうことはね
もう動かすしか何もないんですよ
だからお茶漬けの話で覚えておいてください
これでいいっていう理屈は成り立ちません
心の壁を破って破って破っていること
行くことは単純にご飯に例えたっていいんですよ
あらゆるあらゆるあらゆる食べ物を食べてみることですからね
その方が一番いいでしょうね
毎日決まってる食べ物を食べるんじゃなくて
いろんな日本にしたっても
もうもう数え切れないほどの料理あるでしょうね
もう何でも食べたことあるんだって言ったらすごいでしょうね
1年に 365日しかないのに
それ 365違う違う料理食べてるんだったらすごいことでしょうね
日本料理にしたってもね
もう 1万種類 2万種類以上あるでしょうね
沖縄料理にしたってもどれぐらいありますかね
もし 1日ある一つの食べ物
これは 2度食べる 別のもの食べるぞと思って食べるとすごい世界
それでも広がるでしょうね
ですから 別に壁を破っていくっていうことは何が悪いのかな
食べ物に例えてみたってもわかると思います
はい それでは質問終わり
今の質問なんですけど
壁にぶつかった時から別のことを丁寧に
ちっちゃなことをどんどんチャレンジしていくのがいいのか
それとも壁は壁だって伝わっている妄想してるのを妄想をカットする方がいいのか
妄想をカットすることでいいんじゃない
妄想カットするだけで壁は破れていきます
やり方っていうのはそれほど難しいわけではないんです
もう壁を破らなくちゃとかなんとかいうと
なんかすごいことでね
乗り越えられなくなっちゃいますからね
どうってことないんですよ
妄想やめちゃえばもう全部終わりですからね
だから妄想をカットするんですよ
壁 妄想が作るものでしょ
別に壁じゃないんだからね
妄想でしょ？妄想の壁だからね
壁が妄想 妄想が壁になるんです
だから妄想切っちゃえばいいんです
妄想とその妄想から出てくる刺激
それが甘くてそちらに引っかかってるでしょ
それも捨てちゃう お茶好きもまずいわけないんだけど
その その美味しさにはもう引っかからないぞと
お新香とご飯食べるぞと
というぐらいのことです
だからまあ難しいことじゃないんですよ
壁破ることは  はい よろしいでしょうか
あの 以前先生が木曜日の会で心があるから宇宙があるっておっしゃって
難しい話だから まあ今日は知らないことにしましょうと
それでお話終わっちゃったんですけども
どういう意味なんかなと
半年ぐらいなるんですけれども
ずっと考える  何？心が
心があるから宇宙があります
とおっしゃった それただ認識する話でしょ
認識しなきゃ別にあるともないとも何でもないでしょうに
まずそれで 次にはやっぱり物質の一番優先的なエネルギーは心なんですよ
だからいい加減で 初めは何がありきと聞くならば心になるんです
次に物質が現れると それ正しい答えじゃないんだけど
初めってないんだけどね
まあふざけて一番初めは何よ
初めは心のエネルギーで
その心のエネルギーによって物質が現れてきて
それで巨大な宇宙と無数の生命体ができたんだと言ったって
まあまあ物語として悪くないんです
そういう 2つの意味で心があるから宇宙があるってことになるんです
この 12因縁法則で avijja pacca sankhara 無明に由りて行が生じうる
それ全て心でしょ サンカーラバッチャウィンヤーナ
行に由りて識が生まれる
まだ心でしょ ウィンヤーナバッチャナーローカ
識によって名色が生じる
そこで初めて色が入るんです
物質が入る 物質が構成する前に結構プロセス
心のプロセスがあるんですね
であれはシーケンシャルじゃないんだからね
一応順番で起きたわけじゃなくて
同時に起こるんだから
ちょっと難しくなりますけどね
一応順番で言うならばその順番だから
アヴィッジャーサンカーラウィンヤーナ
次にナーマルーパだから 4番目なんですね
4番目のステージなんですね
物質世界 ということで
おかしい質問かもしれないですけども
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で指導を受けて
瞑想で思考を止めることをしなさいというふうに教わりましたし
本人もタイプいらっしゃるんですけれども
その場合 思考を止めた状態でですね
どうやってサティをやったらよろしいんでしょうか
思考を止める状態っていうのは
この最終的な状態であのサティを完成した状態なんです
いわゆるゴールに行ったところなんですね
普段我々ですね 長老からもそのサティという気づきをしなさいと教わってます
それと日常 そのというと
そのゴールじゃなくて
そのゴールまでたどり着く中断で
そのサティをやる やりなさいというふうにおっしゃっているように解釈しちゃってるんですけども
そうではなくて そのゴールであるというふうに考えてよろしいのでしょうか
何がゴールである？いえ
思考を停止した状態がゴールなんです
妄想が完全止まった瞬間
その瞬間ではもう別にサティも何もできん
はい わかりました ありがとうございます
はい では えーと 時間になりましたので終了いたします
では 回向の文  それでは回向の文をお唱えいたします
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒の守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
ありがとうございます